so let's go back a couple of weeks
because there's a lot of people probably
watching woken up
seen this and thought how the hell has
this happened so let's go through it
right from the to start two weeks ago
well i think to start it two weeks ago
would be to misunderstand the nature of
what's happened i think we have to go
back to 2014
which is when russia first invaded
ukraine this has already happened so it
annexed the crimean peninsula which is
in the south of ukraine and it also
started what was a sort of low-level
civil war uh in the eastern parts of
ukraine in the donetsk and lugansk
regions which is the eastern part of
ukraine
and at that moment in time uh the
reaction from the west was well how can
i put it diplomatically pathetic
uh there was some very weak sanctions
there were some words of condemnation uh
russia was kicked out of the g8 which
you didn't really care about and that
was it and so i think what what the
people who run that country learned
was we can do this
with impunity
and so a few weeks ago what happened is
russia started
massing troops on the border of ukraine
um and uh a couple of days ago vladimir
putin made a speech uh which i think we
really need to talk about in length so
to to to help people understand
why no one's told them what's coming
even though it was immediately obvious
and and we know exactly what's coming
now as well because it's obvious from
what he said right it's just it hasn't
been covered in western media i don't
understand why uh so he amassed these
troops on the border a couple of weeks
ago uh people in the west started
warning about it a lot of people started
saying well this is just saber rattling
it's a distraction uh what we need to do
is just say to putin look ukraine's not
gonna donate if you remember we had this
big argument with nigel farage about
this on our channel
um but that was it was obvious to me
from the beginning that that was never
going to be the way it was going to go
for reasons that i'm sure we'll get into
okay so but why does putin have this
fascination with ukraine why does it go
back to 2014 why did he want to annex
the crimea because surely that's an
anti-antagonistic gesture that means
that he he the sanctions will then be
imposed on russia that will weaken the
russian economy and by doing that
doesn't he weaken his position as leader
well no he strengthens his position as
leader because she's not he's not
answerable to people here in the west is
answerable to the russian population and
to russian people expanding the borders
of russia seen as a great thing if you
remember and this was the case uh here
in the uk and in america only 40 or 50
years ago if you think about margaret
thatcher she was saved by the falklands
war right this was a war about an island
off the coast of argentina which we won
which exactly
so this idea that the greatness of your
country matters uh is something that's
been lost in the west but everywhere
else expanding your borders are seen as
a great thing now as to your question
why there's an invasion now and why
putin is expanding into into uh ukraine
uh he explained all of this in that
speech and this is i think the right
time that we should just break down what
he said it was an extraordinary thing i
don't think anyone in the west has ever
seen anything like it this was a
president of a country who spent an hour
on national television talking about
history
the first 40 minutes of a speech he
talks about the history of russia and
the history of ukraine
and his argument essentially is that the
existence of ukraine
is a historic mistake it should never
have existed
the existence of ukraine is the result
of a series of weak decisions made by
various soviet leaders starting with
vladimir lenin and then nikita
khrushchev and others
and
the the mistake as he sees it is that
the russian people
the russian nation
which was embodied in the soviet union
he was artificially split up
and
a portion of the russian nation was put
together with what he called pieces of
former poland and hungary
and put together into one country which
became ukraine so in his view ukraine is
a mistake uh it shouldn't exist
uh he claims uh in that speech and also
in uh the speech that he gave this
morning uh uh
essentially justifying the invasion that
russian speakers and ethnic russians in
ukraine are being genocided i'm not
exaggerating this is the word he used he
says there's a genocide happening is
there a genocide happening
i mean my family live in in southern and
eastern ukraine and they're russian
speakers i if there was a genocide
happening i think i'd probably find out
about it
but
it doesn't really matter what the truth
is what matters is
what people believe right and if this is
what he believes um then you know that's
one issue and if he's just saying this
in order to justify an invasion that's
another issue both are bad and we can
get into that but
so the first thing to say is he
explained that essentially the russian
nation was split up a piece of poland
and hungary and other countries was
glued onto a piece of russia and made
into a country and these are historic
mistakes that uh he he says a sort of
understandable and difficult time that
the country was in at the time but we
cannot be held by decisions made at that
time
by weak leaders who made these weak
decisions so the first thing that you
should know
um this is why the invasion was always
going to happen because he's essentially
explained that the uk ukraine shouldn't
exist
he explained why it shouldn't exist he
explained the historical reasons um he
also
was he also made some other points along
these lines which is essentially that
the russia after the collapse of the
soviet union
took on the the all of the entire soviet
debt and it paid it off and left as he
sees it to ukraine and other countries
of the former soviet union this great
russian inheritance the land that
russian people had conquered over
centuries the
the great technological achievements the
manufacturing the the ship building all
of that so one of the points he makes as
you said look in ukraine in one of the
southern ports they've just shut down a
shipbuilding
yard
which was the foundations of which were
laid by catherine the grey
the russian
tsar or tyrion or whatever you call her
in english so what he's saying is we the
russians we gave you this stuff
we gave you this great culture this land
these technological advancements and and
you've squandered them
he talks he spends 10 minutes talking
about how russia is corrupt and not
russia sorry
that was a brilliant slip he talks about
ukraine is corrupt how it's run by
oligarchs how um
is that true
of course it's true of course it's true
but the same is true of russia of course
it is right all of that world is run by
oligarchs and is corrupt i mean would
you say that the western world is not
run by oligarchs and is not corrupt it
is right
every country to some extent is run by
oligarchs does that the question is does
that
justify their neighbor invading that
country and taking over that's really
the conversation we're having so um he
he talks a lot about how uh you know
ukrainian education is poor and people
are not looked after and the pensions
are not great and gas prices have gone
up and how terrible things are for
people in ukraine uh so that's the
second part of this speech
which is so the first part is explaining
why ukraine shouldn't exist the second
part is explaining why people in ukraine
are suffering particularly russian
people and russian uh speakers in
ukraine are suffering and the third part
of the speech and this is the final part
of the speech and i don't understand why
it hasn't been reported on i mean the
first few parts are important because
they tell you everything that's going to
happen right if you don't believe
ukraine exists and you believe it is
your historic mission to save the people
in ukraine who are of russian ethnicity
or russian speakers
from being abused by ukrainian oligarchs
you always knew there was going to be an
invasion and you always knew he was
never going to be limited to those two
regions because when he talks about well
you've you've glued on parts of poland
and parts of hungary onto ukraine onto
this russian peace
that means that at least half of ukraine
including the capital kiev
is within the strike zone of what he
wants to achieve
right there's no question about that so
the invasion will not stop in those two
regions in the east unless it is stopped
somehow by the west which at this point
is looking unlikely but his intentions
are not to stop with those two eastern
regions there's no question about that
anyone who tells you otherwise either
doesn't understand or wants it not to be
true or whatever but those are the facts
right he is going to invade
uh as much as he is allowed to and he
wants to invade at least up to kievan
probably beyond
just on in terms of that part of it the
third part of it and the rationale for
his
uh uh invasion
is that he says that
the west is meddling in the affairs of
ukraine the west is meddling in the
affairs of other eastern european
countries the west is expanding nato uh
which he says they say is a defensive
alliance but actually this is a way of
uh putting rockets and missiles and he
goes through all the different rockets
and missiles that the west already has
and is developing
to they want to put them all around
russia so that they could strike at the
heart of russia any moment so he is
literally saying that ukraine is
planning an offensive against these
eastern regions
which you know some people in ukraine
are joking and going yeah we waited
until putin had 200 000 troops on the
border and then we were like hey let's
let's do an aggressive action here
and
the other
thing that he says is essentially the
west is about to attack i mean he he he
doesn't mince words about it he
literally says that he says the west is
getting ready it's putting nuclear and
other sort of missiles in position to
strike against us
and we must defend ourselves now how you
defend yourself by moving your borders
closer to nato i don't really understand
but that is the argument
[Music]